JONATHAN: Well, good
morning and welcome to
Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce the great Jean
Lightman.
Jean is one Boston's most
exceptional representational
artists and teachers.
As a teacher, she passes on
the knowledge and techniques
she has received as one
in the line of Boston
School of painters that has been
unbroken for over a century.
This is a remarkable
lineage that I
believe is unique in the
American art community.
She can describe it
far better than I can,
and I'll leave it
to her to do so.
Jean holds a Distinguished
Artist Membership
at the Concord Art Association
and became a Copley Artist
Member of the Copley
Society, Boston in 2004.
In 1989, she was elected a
Member of the prestigious Guild
of Boston Artists, where
she currently serves
as Vice President of
the Board of Managers,
and curated a major historical
exhibition-- "A Woman's
Perspective: Founding
and Early Women
Members of the Guild of
Boston Artists 1914 to 1945."
Please join me in
welcoming Jane Lightman.
[APPLAUSE]
JEAN LIGHTMAN: Thank you,
Jonathan, and thank you
all for coming today.
It's an honor to
be here at Google
and have the opportunity
to talk with you about art,
and in particular, the
art of the Boston School--
which is not a physical school.
As Jonathan explained,
it's a painting tradition
that's been handed down from
teacher to student for over 100
years.
And in my talk
today, I'll introduce
the Boston School
painters, the founders,
show you the work
of the founders,
and also the European
masters who influenced them,
as well as their successors.
I'll also show you
images of my own work,
and explain how I include
the essential elements
of the Boston School
into my painting.
So the Boston School
painters are essentially
Impressionists in
the sense that they
paint what the eye sees,
with particular attention
to the lights and the
shadows and the colors.
Because they paint what
their eye actually sees,
some areas are more distinct
and others are more diffused.
So they are sometimes
called optical realists.
And this should be distinguished
from photorealists,
where in photorealism painting,
every square inch of the canvas
is painted in precise
detail-- everything
in the exact same focus.
But the way that we actually see
is some areas are more defined
and others are more diffused.
And so that's the way the Boston
School painters like to paint.
As you can see, they
don't all paint alike,
but they're all interested
in how the light falls
across their subject.
And the most important trademark
of the Boston School painters
is that all of the parts
must relate to the whole,
giving the paintings
unity or breadth.
Probably the earliest
Impressionist painter
was Velasquez,
Diego Velasquez, who
painted this beautiful
scene, "Las Meninas."
And you can see
how he has captured
the light and the
relationships of the light
as they fall on the scene,
And pay close attention
to the dwarf and the dog in
the lower right-hand corner,
because they're
beautiful examples
of Impressionist seeing.
Vermeer was another
Impressionist in the way
that we're using this term.
He was fascinated by how
light fell across the scene.
And his paintings have a
truth, or the look of Nature.
You feel like you're in
the room with the subject.
He's arranged the
model next the window.
And he's described how the
light falls across her arm
and across the top of her
head covering, the back wall,
and onto the table.
And he's painted
relational color.
He's one of the first
painters, and really
the only Dutch
painter, to understand
that there's color in
the half tones, which
is the area between the
lights in the shadows.
And here he's painted
this beautiful blue note
in the top of her head covering.
And he's looking at
relational color,
so rather than painting
this brass pitcher and bowl
yellow, as it would
be in life, he's
showing you that it's reflecting
all the colors around it.
So this is relational color
versus absolute color.
And you'll see this
over and over again
in the Boston School paintings.
Chardin also influenced
the Boston School painters.
And he painted beautifully
composed still lifes
using simple kitchen objects.
And note how he paints
these beautiful abstractions
of lights and shadows as
they move across the canvas.
In the late 19th century,
Americans flocked to Europe
to study in the
academies, particularly
in France and Germany.
And they learned there the
essentials of painting,
and it in particular design,
which was the key element-- so
important in academic painting.
And this painting,
by Jean Leon Gerome,
called "Grey Eminence" hangs
in the Museum of Fine Arts.
It's a wonderful example
of academic painting.
And I learned from
a Google search
that "Grey Eminence" refers to
the power behind the throne.
In this case, this monk
standing on the stairs, who
was the power behind the throne
in the court of King Louis
XIII, and Cardinal Richelieu.
Edmund Tarbell is considered the
founder of the Boston School.
In fact, the early painters
were called Tarbellites.
He traveled to France as a
young art student in 1883
and studied in the
Academy Julian.
There he learned
the fundamentals
of drawing and
design and painting.
But he and the other early
Boston School painters--
and I'll show you their
work in a minute--
were influenced also by
the color and the light
of the French Impressionists.
And they incorporated those
two-- the color and light,
and the drawing and design.
And they brought
those back to Boston,
and taught in what became known
as the Boston School tradition.
And note here-- and you
should blur your eyes, which
is the way to look at a
lot of these paintings--
with a blurred eye, you
can see the abstractions
of dark silhouettes
cut into the light
starting on the bottom
left corner of the canvas,
and traveling up and
down and up until he
gets to the upper right corner.
Beautiful abstractions,
and like Vermeer, he's
fascinated with the play of
light across the model's neck
and also across the wall
throughout the whole scene.
This is also by Tarbell, and
a wonderful portrait, again
abstracted seeing of
lights that are silhouetted
against a dark background.
The painter here shows us
the beautiful form and colors
in her face and her arms,
and also in her dress.
And he's seeking
something here that
is, unique, I think, to a lot
of the Boston School painters--
trying to find the beauty, the
whole harmony, and the round
forms that you see when
you look at this scene.
It's reminiscent of John
Singer Sargent's portraits.
And people often ask me if
Sargent was a Boston School
painter, but he was not.
He painted in Europe,
studied in Europe
like the Boston painters.
But his paintings are
a little bit different,
and as you can see, the
model is-- he's a genius,
and I'm not taking
anything away from Sargent.
He was an absolutely
superb, phenomenal painter
in a number of different
genres, not just portrait.
But he's not seeking out
the subtle color tones
in the round form, in the
face, in the neck, in the arms,
which I think you can see here.
He's painting sort of a
lively, painterly ensemble
of lights and darks.
Frank Benson was another
early Boston School painter.
And he, like Tarbell, studied
at the Academy Julian in Paris.
His outdoor paintings
glow with sunlight.
As you can see here,
he's also fascinated
by the colors-- the
relational colors-- the blues
and the yellows on her dress,
also on the inside of the boat,
and on his son's shirt.
These are his children here.
The whole painting is
a wonderful ensemble
of blues and yellows,
with a little hint of reds
in here for some interest.
Benson was also an
avid outdoorsman.
And he also did beautiful
etchings and paintings
of wildlife.
And notice here his
wonderful designs--
what's called
negative shapes here
of the inside of the
wings of the Canada geese,
and how he's spaced them.
He sort of has a
wonderful rhythm here
that's played out from
here to here to here.
It's a really beautiful example
of design-- very simple design.
And Benson was a master at that.
Another early Boston
School painter
was Joseph DeCamp, who studied
with Frank Duveneck in Germany.
Notice here, this is
also a wonderful example
of what's essential to
the Boston School, which
is lost and found.
So a found edge is where
the light and the shadow
are contrasted.
And so this would be a
found edge here-- the shadow
against the background.
Also you have to look
closely, but her chin
here against the
background is a found edge.
This is a lost edge
under her neck.
So this just dissolves
into the background.
The same thing with
the back of her hair
that dissolves into the back
of her neck and shoulder,
and then all the way
down into the apron.
And now look at how her apron
dissolves into the tabletop--
the shadows on the tabletop.
And then this wonderful still
life here of porcelain objects
is a great example
of lost and found.
So this is a found edge
here, which is sharp here
against the black of her apron.
This would be a lost
edge, where the other side
of this porcelain dissolves
into the background.
So you'll see lost and found
repeated in a lot of the Boston
School work.
William Paxton studied
with Joseph DeCamp,
our previous painter.
And Paxton excelled at
interiors, very much influenced
by Vermeer.
This is a painting at the
Museum of Fine Arts called
"The New Necklace."
This is another wonderful
painting by Paxton,
also at the Museum of Fine
Arts, and another great example
of lost and found, and also
beautiful impressionist color.
So you see here some
lost edges here.
And very simple,
not highly defined,
lights and shadows in
the face which dissolve
into the back of the neck.
But you really have to see
this painting at the museum
to appreciate the
absolutely gorgeous colors
that the artist puts into
her back and also her arm.
And notice the
beautiful form on both.
His wife, Elizabeth Paxton,
was also a wonderful painter.
And she excelled at
still-life paintings.
Here she makes this terrific
ensemble of a mess of objects.
It's called "The
Breakfast Tray."
And she has a variety of
edges here and angles.
So here's a sharp angle
here around a sharp edge
on the edge of the
cup-- beautiful variety
of edges in the napkin, and
also wonderful color ensembles.
These yellows and blues
harmonize beautifully.
And then she has a little
note of red here for interest.
William Paxton's
student, Ives Gammell,
was responsible for
carrying the tradition
on through the 20th century.
He taught a number of students
in the '40s, '50s, '60s,
and '70s, when this tradition
was very much out of favor
with the art establishment and
the art schools of the day.
Gammell loved painting these
sort of allegorical paintings.
But again, note the beautiful,
harmonious color relationships.
I love the blues and the
yellows in this painting.
And then he has also
some notes of red.
The Boston School tradition
would have surely died out
if it hadn't been for Gammell.
And a number of his students
have gone on to teach,
including my teacher.
One of his early students
was Robert Douglas Hunter.
You might be familiar
with his still lifes.
He was a very well known
still-life painter,
and also noted for his
harmonious compositions.
He painted what he said,
all Nature in one glance.
And it does feel like
this classical still life
has a beautiful harmony
or unity about it.
Gammell's student--
one of his students--
was Paul Ingbretson,
who was my teacher.
And Paul excelled
at-- he's also gone on
to teach dozens of painters
over the last 30 years,
and now in Manchester, New
Hampshire has an atelier.
Paul excels at portraits, still
lifes, interiors, figures.
And this is a beautiful
portrait of a dancer,
one of my favorites of his.
And he uses the full
use of relational color,
beautiful color transitions
between the warm notes
on her cheek, across the
first round form on her cheek,
to the cooler blue notes at
the edge of her jaw-- also
beautiful, soft, round
edge at the edge of her jaw
and across her neck.
And more than that-- more than
the technical accomplishments
of this painting-- he's
infused the portrait
with expression and life.
This is Paul Ingbretson's
atelier in New Hampshire.
And this is one of his
cast drawing students.
When the student begins to study
in the Boston School tradition,
the first thing you do is
you do charcoal drawings
of these white plaster casts.
And that's what this
student is doing here.
And that's what I did when
I first started studying
in the late '80s with Paul.
So this is my cast drawing.
And it's the perfect
teaching tool.
It's the opportunity
for the teacher
to what's called "true
the eye" of the student
to recognize values
and proportions.
Everything is seen relationally.
So I learned to see the height
in relation to the width.
I learned to see how my
values-- how dark my shadows had
to be in order to make
my lights pop out,
and get what's called a
light effect, which is
so important in this painting.
And I also learned to
distinguish a variety of edges,
as I've already pointed out.
So there are sharp edges
where the value contrasts
are the highest.
And then in order to
describe the form,
I had to learn to
understand softer edges,
and how to make
things look round.
And of course, in
Socrates' beard here,
I had infinite
opportunity to do that.
This is Paul's
teaching studio and
where I studied in
Roxbury back in the '80s.
And a few things to point
out about the studios
for these Boston School
painters-- first of all,
you notice that the wall
color is a middle value.
It's not white.
We never use white
walls, because the light
bounces all over white walls.
And so it's hard to see what the
light is doing on your set up.
This is the set up here.
Also, we have high north light,
because north light is steady.
There's no sun shining
through to change the shadows,
so the shadows are fairly
consistent throughout the day.
Another thing I want to
point out is in our painting,
we actually have to stand back
from the setup and the easel
at least three times the
height of the painting
so that you can see the
whole thing at once.
Because obviously, you're
trying to get harmony or unity.
So you have to be
able to see all
of the relationships--
the values
and the colors and
the proportions-- all,
as Robert Hunter
said, in one glance.
So you stand back.
And then you look at the
painting and the setup.
And then you actually walk
up and paint from memory.
So I'm not looking
at the set up when
I'm painting this painting--
just an interesting note.
So I studied with Paul
for almost 10 years,
and finally cut the umbilical
cord in the early '90s,
and started painting
on my own in a studio
in Concord, Massachusetts.
And I enjoy doing portraits
of kids-- children.
I've also-- because they
have nice, round forms
in their faces, and I love that.
I also like doing landscapes.
This is a painting of the
Minuteman statue with the North
Bridge in Concord.
But my passion is flowers,
and in particular peonies.
What I love about them
are the round shapes.
And just like the figures
with the white dresses
in the earlier
paintings that you saw,
I get very excited
by all of the colors
that I see in the half-tones
between the lights
and the shadows.
So these white peonies
have an infinite variety
of color in those half-tones.
I also love the variety
of shapes in the peonies,
and colors, and sizes.
And here I also am
painting hydrangeas.
Those are also fun to paint.
And most of all, for me
peonies have a real life force
about them.
I entitled this painting
"Chi" because the challenge
for me is to get the life,
the essence of these peonies.
And so this is "Chi"
for that reason.
So I want to explain to, show
you, how I actually set up
a design, make an
arrangement, and then decide--
until I'm satisfied with it.
Because as Benson said,
design makes the picture.
Good painting can
never save a picture
if the composition is bad.
So in this setup, I was
interested in getting what's
called a chiaroscuro effect.
I was interested in a
very dark background
with bright flowers shining out
with a lot of light on them.
The problem with this,
though, as I sat with it
for a few days, was
that there really
wasn't a good, powerful
center of interest.
Everything was pretty
similar, so there
are a lot of little
flecks here, and not
particularly eye-catching.
So I added in some white
peonies for interest,
and started playing
around with these.
But the problem here was
that they were too spotty.
So I've got one here,
one here, one here.
And I'm not really interested
in sort of individual peonies.
I'm interested in massing them
together, and seeing what they
do as a big, abstract shape.
So I started doing
that and trying
to get something interesting.
And notice also that I'm
starting to play around
with the background flowers--
make those harmonize
with the center of
interest, because you
want your background
to accentuate it.
But you don't want
it to take away
from the center of interest.
As Paul used to say you
don't want something
on the backstage to be
jumping out saying look at me.
Look at me.
So you're interested in a
center of interest that's
complemented by the background.
So I'm continuing
for a few days.
This was interesting, but it was
a little too symmetrical here.
Now I'm getting a
little bit closer.
And finally, this is
the finished painting
that I was happy
with in the design.
There's some interesting
negative shapes.
There's an interesting
mass of light here.
A movement or gesture
among the flowers that's
accentuated by the background,
and then also, notes of red
and-- it's predominantly a
yellow and blue painting.
And I consider the green to
be part of the yellow family.
And then I've added
some, for interest,
some coral notes here.
So now I'll show you start
to finish how I actually
do a painting.
And this is another
setup in my studio.
And the canvas, as you
can see, is side by side.
And I'm standing fairly
far back in order
to see the whole thing at once.
So these would be
my first marks.
Really this is maybe the
first 20 minutes of working,
with a very large brush
and a very blurred eye,
because I'm looking to see
the big abstractions of light
as it falls across this setup.
And also the
biggest color values
that I can find-- so this is
sort of the approximate color
and value of the lightest area,
which would be the peonies.
And then this is
the background--
the dark notes around it.
Actually, this is
the background.
This is the dark shadow.
So I'm trying to get them in
approximately the right place.
This is now I'm getting more
of the lay-in, it's called.
So this would be the
first, probably 30 minutes
or one hour of doing
this painting-- again,
big abstractions of
light and shadows.
I'm not painting objects.
I'm painting masses of light.
So for that reason, you
can see that there's
along one edge on one
side of the flower
that I'm starting to delineate.
And what I'm
interested in here is
how that edge dissolves into
the dark shadow along the vase,
and where that is in
approximate relation
to the edge of the canvas.
So I'm continuing to
search for my light masses.
I'm letting tones dissolve
into the background that
are called half-tones.
I'm looking for
the leading edge.
These would be the
arabesque, it's called.
There are no lines in Nature, so
I don't paint around anything.
I'm just painting edges
and the variety of edges
that my eye sees.
And also, you might
notice that I've only
painted the left
side of this vase,
because for compositional
reasons, that
was very important to me.
For one thing, the shadow
dissolves into this shadow.
But also, the arm here
has a relationship
to the arc of this flower up
here and through this shadow.
This was very important
to me in the design.
And I want to make
sure that I've
got this fairly well
delineated at an early stage
of the painting.
And then there's sort of a
secondary line or movement
here.
So-- and this would
be what's called
this the big look or the start.
At this point, I've got
everything going pretty well.
I've got the visual
order, so the areas
that jump out at your eye
when you blur your eyes
also come forth or come
forward on the canvas.
And areas that dissolve
recede on the canvas.
So this is what my eye
sees when I blur it
with a very blurred eye.
I'm also looking for
shifts-- shifts of value
and also shifts of color.
So I'm looking for where
my yellows dissolve
into blue notes and just
color shifts all over here.
Also, it has the appearance
of images coming out
of a fog, which is also
that lost and found look.
So the rest will be refinements.
So I'll go area by area
now, and start painting
the top left here was one area.
So again, I'm not
painting objects.
I'm painting areas
of light and shadow
and where they dissolve
into one another.
This is also-- when I'm
working area by area,
I'm working in a way
that we call painting
from the back straggler.
So if you can imagine a shepherd
who's herding a flock of sheep
from one pasture to the next,
he moves that big flock of sheep
along, but he might
have a small group
that's sort of lagging behind.
And those are his
back stragglers.
So he goes and he pulls
those flock of sheep forward.
And then another flock
of sheep will lag behind.
So we're painting from
the back straggler here.
And in this case, you're trying
to get the whole ensemble
moving pretty much at once.
But obviously, you have
to paint area by area.
You can't paint the whole
painting all at one time.
So the back straggler
for me would
be this bottom right-hand area.
And that's what I
would have painted
in probably the next--
after I painted this area,
I would've gone and
painted in this area.
So I'm also pushing
the light effect here,
looking for big color shifts.
And at this point, everything
is pretty well defined.
And I'm fairly happy
with it, but it
doesn't have the harmony
or the unity of the setup,
of the concept that
I'm looking for.
And it's important to understand
we're not copying, simply
blindly copying, Nature.
We're looking for something
bigger-- that breadth
that I was talking
about earlier.
So I'm working day
to day, pulling back,
looking for the
biggest relationships
I can see, with the big, blurred
eye with these hydrangeas
and how they relate
to the whole ensemble.
I often use a mirror, which
I look at upside down,
because it reverses everything
backwards and upside down.
And it helps me see
with a very fresh eye.
So this was my
finished painting.
And I couldn't find any
more back stragglers here.
It has the harmony that I was
looking for, and the big look.
It also has the vibrancy in
the lights and the shadows.
And unity-- strong light effect,
magical color relationships--
all very important
in this painting.
So I wanted to just
tell you a little bit
about-- you can see a lot of the
early Boston School paintings
at the Museum of Fine Arts.
And contemporary Boston
School painters-- a number
of us are Members of the
Guild of Boston Artists, which
was founded by
Tarbell and Benson
and DeCamp and the early
Boston School painters.
It's a nonprofit gallery
on Newbury Street,
and continues today.
We just celebrated
our 100th anniversary.
So this is actually a photo
of the gallery in 1914
for the inaugural exhibition.
And the gallery is still there.
This mantle is still there.
And now they're paintings of
contemporary Boston School,
and also other wonderful
painters painting
in different
traditions-- tonalists,
Hudson River School--
some fabulous painters.
So I encourage you to take
a look at the gallery,
and see these
paintings for yourself.
Some of the-- just a
few of those painters
are Mary Minifie, who's a
wonderful portrait painter
and also does beautiful still
lifes, David Curtis, who's
also a student of Ives
Gammell, like my teacher.
And he paints wonderful
landscapes on the North Shore,
Anita Johnson, who paints
all kinds of figurative work
as well as still life,
and Pamela Pindell, who
was a student of Robert
Hunter's, and does
a number of different
paintings as well as
sculpture and beautiful
drawings, as you can see here.
So thank you very much.
Also, I appreciate being able
to use the images from the Art
Renewal Center.
And so I'll take any
questions that you have.
JONATHAN: That was great.
Thank you.
I'm curious-- given the
longevity of the Boston School,
is there any obligation
on the part of you
as a student or other students
to go out and become teachers
on your own?
JEAN LIGHTMAN: Yes, absolutely.
I'm deeply appreciative
of Paul Ingbretson,
because he is passing this on.
And there are other teachers,
other people teaching this,
actually throughout the country.
But I think we, as students,
do have an obligation
to pass it on.
And I do some teaching myself.
Mary Minifie also teaches.
David Curtis teaches.
So there are a number of
us who are endeavoring
to pass this very
valuable painting
traditional on to
the next generation.
So if there are
no more questions,
I thank you all
for coming today.